how do you in your role of advising
advising people who have serious wealth
significant wealth and you can help them
with your analysis and guide them to
purely philanthropic ends or you could
advise them to invest in the took took
clean energy example so you can actually
say in a bed net way and say we can save
babies immediately by having medicated
bed nets distributed or you can actually
use your funds in this way how do you
make how do you as an advisor make such
a call and do you ever find yourself
trying to steer them in one direction or
the other or you leave it up to them I I
don't find myself trying to steer them
in one direction or the other unless
clearly I'm representing a particular
product where I'm where I'm trying to
fundraise that's a very different
scenario but i think that the hopefully
the biggest impact that we can have is
clarity and helping them to articulate
their own agenda and priorities and in
some cases although this can sound room
was condescending there is a blurring in
their own minds of the of the
distinction between impact investing
like the took took example and and and
the bed net example and even within bed
nets one could intersect in that in in
in a more commercial way and in a purely
philanthropic way so i think what we're
trying to do is we're trying to help
them articulate a set of priorities in
their in their activities that that that
goes through the gamut of opportunities
by geography by sector by type of
transaction are they interested in debt
or equity are they interested in gender
issues are they interested in infectious
disease but i think that in to answer
your question in my advisory work one is
generally dealing with people back to
the example we used earlier that have
already in their minds drawn a
distinction between what we might call
you know pure giving and something where
they want to participate in an equal
development story as they see it and
therefore can also get excited sometimes
about seeing that money regenerated into
almost like a mini revolving fund within
their wealth of it they can then put
back to back to use in another
opportunity